take a look at this video that Ian just
told me to pull up it is yatin Chu says
this video is going viral on WeChat fish
Village a restaurant in College Point
Queens was ransacked by a gang of masked
kids and hoodies we've fallen so low
that there's no expectation of
consequences for this horrific attack on
private property and uh here's the video
hey man what the
it's crazy
[Music]
just a bunch of people in masks and
hoodies
they don't take anything they didn't
take anything they just destroy it all
that's all they did you have no property
rights in New York City wait did any of
these guys get arrested of course not
come on
look look I'm assuming they didn't get
arrested but why would they get arrested
it's New York true true I was just I
guess I was still hopeful but you got
Eric Adams saying stop wearing masks and
doors because of this stuff or he's
telling businesses to make people remove
their masks why would anybody open a
business in New York it's already gonna
cost you um it's gonna cost like
literally you probably need at least a
million dollars to open a business I
imagine and then you're gonna have
people ransack it the cops aren't going
to do anything if you if someone attacks
you and you defend yourself you're gonna
go to jail there is nothing at all
attractive about New York there's this
old this old Trope an old joke about
someone buys a house in an area and then
they go out and they hear a gunshot one
day and they panic and they you know
they they look outside and there's a
neighbor standing in the yard and he
says he waves them off and they come
outside and did you hear that he goes no
no worry about it you know once a week
or so I fire one off to keep the
property the property taxes low like
there's an old joke about that or
something like a TV show yeah there's a
tick tock that's what they're doing it
feels like what's happening in New York
people are fleeing wealthy people are
fleeing and we already heard from de
Blasio a while during the pandemic he
was going to buy up these buildings for
pennies on the dollar and convert them
into government housing
so it is what's happening being allowed
to happen so that the property values of
New York collapses so the state can
seize it all up for pennies on the
dollar and then
might be elements of it I think it's
overwhelmed I think that the the law
enforcement's overwhelmed I mean just
the group of how many are there 18 15
people like even they're probably half
of them are armed I don't know I guess
the New York City Police Department is
like the sixth largest army on Earth
thirty four thousand 34 000 police
officers they're not outgunned oh yeah
they are 30 000 versus 17 million people
no no no talking about against yeah that
would be that 17 million people were
criminals they're not like the number of
criminals in a in a city matters because
like the people that are committing
crime are the people that continuously
commit crime the reason that people
their crime goes up or it's been going
up is because they let people that are
criminals out of jail to commit more
crimes yeah that so look I'm a New
Yorker and a bunch of my buddies are on
the NYPD and I served with them when I
was on the joint terrorism task force
what they're doing now is they're
literally standing there because they're
not allowed to go and make these arrests
they're not allowed to go and do these
searches and everybody has body cams and
they have to be on at all times and
they're not allowed to go do the basic
police work the stop and frisk and they
can't stop people like this because they
know the attorneys the attorney generals
and the State Attorney General's offices
will Chuck cases out that they bring
like this because it doesn't meet a
specific narrative it's a compounding
effect this is why New York City is
terrible now it's not the New York I
grew up in back in the day and people
don't want to go over there anymore and
it's why people are leaving they're
moving to Florida and Texas and wherever
Idaho is Western Union or West Virginia
yeah you know I heard that's the best
place to be
yeah we've got uh some new friends who
are in New York for a while they're down
in this area now and so it's it's close
enough to a bunch of airports West
Virginia itself is still this beautiful
mountain country but if you drive north
a couple hours you're in Pittsburgh you
drive to the east couple an hour or so
you're in DC and go South to Richmond so
there's there's urban life you know we
can fly people in that's not there's
opportunity out here but people are
leaving the city and I have to wonder if
it's on purpose that's that's the point
we talk about how they're not allowed to
arrest these people and that's that's an
interesting question
why would that be the case what does the
city gain by telling police not to
arrest in charge it's a it's a
combination narrative it's not a one-off
the the left set out to have an opposite
of a law enforcement agenda they said no
cash bail we are going to let everybody
arrested even for severe felonies out on
the streets we are going to let illegal
immigrants uh charged with other crimes
and then we find out we're illegals
we're not going to detain them we're
going to release them when you do all
that and you bring in people to the
justice system and you tell your
prosecutors we're not going to charge
low-level drug offenses we're not going
to charge low-level robberies it's a
compounding effect that basically says
to low-level offenders you're going to
get away with this and even if you're a
medium to Serious level offender there's
now a 50 50 chance no one catches you
and if they do the charges might get
dropped so what do criminals do become
bigger criminals and that New York City
San Francisco Chicago
last year
literally had a child under the age of
five shot a month one child under the
age of five shot a month and killed
that doesn't happen in any other City
unless you're in Lori Lightfoot who just
got the boot because they said we are
not going to take on gang violence we're
not going to take on gun crimes and when
you're arrested for one of those you're
right back on the street we're not doing
cash bail and there's theory that goes
along with why they don't do why they
want to not prosecute right so the to
the left people that commit crimes
they're victims of society circumstances
so if they're a victim of society
circumstance and they carry out a crime
and they victimize someone else if you
punish the person that carried out the
crime you've literally made two victims
you've double victimized them so they
victimized the person that they attack
or whatever but they're already a victim
of society so if Society punishes them
they're a victim again so Society is
victimizing them over and over and it's
it's creating more crime is according to
the left now I think that is a load of
crap but that's the that's the the
philosophy and the theory behind the
idea of no cash bail let people out of
jail if they've committed Petty crimes
Etc so I mean whether or not you believe
that theory or not that is the the
working ideology and why the policies
are being implemented the way they are
and the Genesis was this farce that they
were somehow trying to solve a racial
inequity in the criminal justice system
by saying oh this is unfair to black and
brown people
um so we have to do a total 180 on
supporting anything Law and Order you
don't have the hypocrisy of it all is do
you want to know the two individuals
have put more black people in prison
than any two individuals in American
history Barack Obama no Kamala Harris
and Joe Biden Kamala Harris when she was
the Attorney General of California in
prison more black men than any attorney
general in the state of California's
history Joe Biden implemented wrote and
drafted and passed the 98 crime bill
which imprisoned more black men for
cocaine and crack possession than any
crime bill in U.S history was that 98 or
94 90 98 oh yeah and then didn't uh
Trump worked on uh Criminal Justice
Criminal Justice Reform actual reform
actual reform that's funny and he's the
racist guy he's a racist like Joe
Biden's been in all so he employed some
odd years Trump employed a brown guy so
he's a racist guy oh yeah well but you
know you're the I'm the token white guy
no the uh are you are you Indian is it
I'm Indian yeah the Indian face of white
supremacy yeah let me make sure I got it
right Larry Elder is the black face of
white right right that's true I like
that
it's it's it's look anyone who who pays
attention knows that there's a
meaningless statement but the fact that
someone Falls for The Narrative of Larry
Elder blackface of white supremacy it's
like if you're gonna fall for that I
don't know how we how we communicate
with these people and affect change you
can't well they're voting what do you do
you got to be a beacon a lighthouse but
don't shine the light directly in their
eyes because of the line doesn't cause
them pain you got to just be there for
when they need you you need to we need
to get the ideologies out of the schools
I think I think one of the reasons for
going up to schools is to make sure
people are so stupid they will always
just vote 100
absolutely 100 the more time you spend
actually thinking about the Dynamics of
Oppression when you're in math class the
less time you're spending on math and
history yeah that's literally the point
like they want to have generative issues
they want to have issues that teach
Politics as opposed to the topic they're
supposed to be learning and eventually
that will turn into like buildings
falling down in your society and planes
not getting off the ground and Chernobyl
yeah you need for math it's a language
you need people that are like
autistically observant of math it's not
diffuse not like distracted by anything
really a bad home life people telling
you you're racist because of your skin
color like you need to be able to do
calculations and build buildings good
point real life translation of math is
architecture it's acceptable to teach
politics and have kids learn politics
but it there are you don't want to do it
in every single class and that's what
the influence of the left is doing
they're using they're using math and
they're using English and they're using
uh you know whatever whatever course
they can to generate political questions
that's the whole reason with the the
LGBT issues in school they use that to
generate political questions among
children so they can teach kids
political ideology according to angelism
been school choice is popping off I'm
trying to find some tweets from him but
something big happened now we've got 26
to eight vote in Arkansas Senate passed
the governor's Bill to fund students
instead of systems according to core
DeAngelis passed the house 78-21 goes to
uh Governor Huckabee that stuff is that
stuff is good and it's it's not a bad
thing but you the problem that's going
on in our schools now is in the schools
of education so it's all of the teachers
so it doesn't matter if you're going
with a this school or that school if
you're going to the public school or
you're going to the private school if
they're all getting teachers that went
to the same schools you see the problem
it's if your your schools of Education
your schools that teach teachers how to
be teachers if they're teaching teachers
to use the methods that are that are
critical theories essentially then
that's going to be put into all of your
schools so whether it's your private
schools your public schools whatever
they're all corrupted thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time